dizzi knows how to make some epic movies
and they also are really good at
shocking us there have been some crazy
Disney plot twists over the years stay
tuned to find out the most shocking plot
twist of all Flynn cuts Rapunzel's hair
in 2010 Disney decided to take on the
classic fairy tale of Rapunzel in the
movie tangled the Disney Princess
version is a great tale of adventure and
love
Rapunzel is locked in a tower by Mother
Gothel bothell stole Rapunzel as a baby
because her hair has magical powers that
keep Gothel young Rapunzel just thinks
her mom is overprotective and all she
wants to do is see the lights on her
birthday Flynn Rider is a thief who
escaped soldiers by climbing into
Rapunzel's tower he agrees to help her
get to the floating lights and along the
way the to fall in love we were already
shook when Flynn revealed his real name
was Eugene he just doesn't look like a
Eugene at all but the real plot twist
came a little later
Eugene escapes from prison and goes back
to the tower to save Rapunzel he's
injured and is bleeding out Rapunzel
wants to save him by using her hair but
he leans forward to try to kiss her or
so we think
he cuts off her hair and it loses all of
its magic Flynn spends a lot of the
movie very selfish but he cuts her hair
to save her even though he knows her
pencil could heal him
thankfully Rapunzel's tears save his
life so they can live happily ever after
mordioux is a human brave is the only
Disney princess movie to be made by
Pixar Merida is different from all the
other princesses in several ways she's
determined to live her own fate and that
does not include getting married she and
her mom Queen Eleanor fight about
Merida's refusal to marry one of her
suitors and become a proper princess
Merida runs off and finds a witch she
asks for a spell that will change her
mom I want a spell to change my mom but
she didn't mean for the change to be
quite so literal Eleanor turns into a
bear then her husband King Fergus
attacks her he thinks that she is more
do the ancient bear who is the greatest
enemy Merida and Eleanor run off into
the woods for safety
Eleanor starts to act like a real bear
every now and then and they realized if
they don't change her back she'll become
a real bear Merida finds drawings in an
and castle of four brothers one brother
went his own way and he was cursed he
became more do we did not see that
coming at all he was actually a human
mordioux is defeated when a standing
stone falls on him his human spirit is
released and he looks super relieved
that he's allowed to move on now Lotso
is evil we're pretty sure there is
nothing less evil than a teddy bear at
least we used to think so before we saw
at Toy Story 3 Andy is all grown up and
about to head to college his mom
accidentally takes his toys to a daycare
as donations Sunnyside daycare seems
like an awesome place he'll get played
with every day and all the daycare toys
seem so friendly especially the leader
lot so woody wants to get back to Andy
so he leaves he's taken in by Bonnie the
other toys quickly realized that
Sunnyside daycare is no paradise the
toddlers that play with them are brutal
buzz tries to get Lotso to transfer the
toys to the older kids playroom but
Lotso refuses he captures buzz and turns
him back to factory settings when the
toys try to escape to get back to Andy
Lotso has them imprisoned that is one
evil bear it turns out that Lotso is
angry because his original owner Daisy
replaced him but that doesn't mean he
needs to be mean to the other toys Lotso
then tries to destroy all the toys at
the dump in the most intense scene ever
the lot so Dunn ends up spending the
rest of his life strapped to the front
of a truck
yikes Maleficent can turn into a dragon
we're kicking it old school for this
next plot twist Sleeping Beauty came out
way back in 1959 Princess Aurora is
christened and the three God fairies
give her blessings my gift shall be the
gift of songs Maleficent the mistress of
all evil shows up she is super offended
that she didn't get invited to the
christening she curses the baby Princess
Aurora will prick her finger on her 16th
birthday and she will not survive
Maleficent leaves the fairy Merryweather
uses her blessing to change the curse if
Aurora pricks her finger she will fall
into a deep sleep that can be broken by
true love's kiss
then the fairies take her away to try to
keep her safe from ever pricking her
finger but Maleficent is one smart
sorceress she
lures arora to a castle and she pricks
her finger on the spinning wheel Prince
Phillip is in love with Aurora and he
has been kidnapped
he fights Maleficent but then she turns
into a giant fire-breathing dragon talk
about an unfair fight people have been
shocked by this magical transformation
for generations
somehow Phillip manages to defeat the
dragon he kisses Aurora and breaks the
spell and they live happily ever after
as the princess should syndrome is buddy
pines the opening scene of The
Incredibles shows mr. incredible
Elastigirl and Frozone fighting crime it
was the glory days of superheroes mr.
incredible has a huge fan named Buddy
Pines this annoying kid shows up at the
worst times he wants to be a superhero
and he calls himself incrediboy the mr.
incredible is fed up and he sends him
away the supers end up causing major
damage and they are all sent into hiding
as regular civilians fast forward 15
years mr. incredible and Elastigirl are
married with three kids mr. incredible
really hates living a normal life he's a
superhero after all he is recruited by a
woman named Mirage to help defeat a
robot this robot was trained to solve
any problem but then it went raw mr.
incredible lies to his family and goes
to help Mirage soon he meets syndrome
the evil creator of the robot he is a
smart supervillain but he isn't just
some random guy he is buddy pine aka
incredible as a boy he was so upset by
mr. incredible shunning him that he
turned evil he wants to get rid of all
supers and convinced the world that he's
a hero but he's no match for the
Incredibles Ponce is evil frozen is one
of the most popular Disney movies ever
after Elsa's ice powers almost destroy
her little sister the kingdom of
arendelle is closed off their parents
are lost at sea and Anna is lonely Elsa
is set to be coronated as queen of
arendelle Anna is so excited to see
other people for the first time in
forever she goes out of the castle and
runs into a handsome young prince named
Hans they have the cutest song about
love and at this point we're totally
shipping them
Hans proposes and Anna says yes but Elsa
points out that you can't marry someone
you just met
you asked for my blessing but my answer
is no she gets angry and her glove comes
off revealing her icy powers Anna leaves
Hans in charge and goes after her sister
she meets Olaf and Kristoff Anna and
Kristoff have way better chemistry than
she did with Hans we were seriously
conflicted about who we shipped with
Anna Hans goes to the ice castle and
fights marshmallow he insists that no
harm comes to Elsa and we still think
he's a decent guy but then he takes Elsa
and locks are in a dungeon he traps Anna
and confesses that he doesn't love her
as the youngest of 13 brothers he would
never be keen he planned to marry Anna
and then arrange for an accident to get
rid of Elsa and he could be king of
arendelle
he continues to lie and manipulate
everyone think that's a huge plot twist
keep watching to find out the biggest
disney plot twist ever tuppen saves the
banks family our next major plot twist
is from the brand-new movie Mary Poppins
returns the banks children are all grown
up Michael Banks has three kids and his
wife passed away they're broke and their
house is going to be taken away Michael
and Jane search the house for a piece of
paper that proves their father had
shares in the bank it will be enough to
save the house but they can't find it
Mary Poppins shows up to help care for
the children the youngest finds a
drawing in the garbage and he uses it to
patch up the kite from the first movie
the first plot twist was that the bank
president was evil the kids realize it
but Michael and Jane do not they pack up
their house unable to find the shares
but then Michael sees that the paper on
the kite was the shares document they
rushed to the bank and Mary Poppins
helps turn back time so they reached
their deadline the document is
incomplete and the bank president thinks
to use one then his uncle the old
president shows up he kicks out his
nephew and he tells Michael to keep
those shares Michael has his own in the
first movie little Michael wants to
spend his tuppence that's two pennies to
feed the birds but he's convinced to put
it in the bank
his dad invests it and it turns into a
big sum of money those two bunnies saved
the day
bellwether is the villain Zootopia was a
fun movie about a world full of talking
animals predators and prey lived
together in peace
but bunny officer Judy Hopps soon
realizes something evil is going on
predators are going
wild losing their ability to reason she
and criminal Nick Wilde have to
investigate because no one will take
them seriously if you'll excuse us we
have a very big lead to follow and a
case to crack assistant mayor bellwether
is kind of adorable she's a shy sweet
little sheep but she is what the phrase
a wolf in sheep's clothing is all about
she hates predators and she feels that
she'll never amount to anything as a
prey animal she's been capturing animals
and giving them a serum to make them
turn wild Judy and Nick never saw it
coming and neither did we though whether
tried to destroy the evidence but she
was defeated never judge a book by its
cover
once she's gone everything is back to
normal Zootopia is once again a place of
peace Judy Hopps is recognized as a
great cop even though she's a prey
animal maybe bellwether should have used
a different approach to get respect for
prey tikka is tough et mallanna is the
most recent Disney princess movie it has
a huge plot twist that we did not see
coming at the beginning of the movie we
find out how the heart of taffy T was
stolen
taffy T was an island goddess who
created all life for heart which is a
stone was stolen by the demigod Maui as
Maui left the island he was met by a
lava monster named tikka in the fight
now he lost his magical fish hook and
the heart of two feet II the heart
appears to Moana a millennium later
lalana goes on an adventure to restore
to feed his heart and save her people
from starvation she finds Maui and
convinces him to help they fight take ha
and Maui abandons her but Moana returns
she gets past Akkad to return the heart
and Maui returns but Moana realizes that
the island is gone taffy T turned into
tayka when her heart was stolen even
gentle goddesses get angry right once
the heart is restored to fede is back
and touka is gone and Moana leads her
people back to the sea where they belong
Penelope stays in the Internet Ralph
breaks the Internet is the epic sequel
to Rekha Trowell said about six years
after the first movie Ralph and
vanellope are best friends Ralph is
really happy now that he has friends and
is respected in his game Penelope loves
Ralph but she's kind of bored with her
game she has done all the tracks Ralph
tries to help by making a new game but
this ends up freaky
the game Litwack unplugs sugar rush and
has plans to junk it oh the sugar rush
characters are left without homes
penelope seems devastated that the only
home she knows is gone she and ralph
head to the internet to find the piece
to fix her game while she's there
penelope discovers an Internet racing
game called slaughter race she loves it
it's scary and far from boring she makes
friends with the character Shane Ralph
and vanellope end up getting the
steering wheel for sugar rush
but then vanellope totally shocks us she
decides to stay in slaughter race she
seemed so sad when she thought sugar
rush was fun that we were sure she would
return and she left find Roald we
couldn't believe it but she is a lot
happier in slaughter race and she and
Ralph talked on the phone we did not
expect her to stay in the Internet at
all which Disney plot twist left you
shocked let us know in the comments
below and those are 10 of the most
jaw-dropping Disney plot twists be sure
to like this video and wreck that big
red subscribe button see you next time
[Music]